[Musique]
le Conseil départemental a organisé ce
jeudi 7 décembre au jardin de l'État un
événement festif à destination des
jeunes de 16 à 29 ans intitulé Revel
talent talent c'est un espace pour les
jeunes avec les jeunes pour les inviter
à N faire connaître une part leur talent
jeun r du talent mais également les
préoccupations qui les concerneobjectif
pour nous au niveau du conseilemental de
pouvoir amener les jeunes à nous
accompagner
par une journée qui leur a permis de
profiter de divers ateliers d'écouter
des humoristes de participer à des
forums sur les thèmes qui les
préoccupent mais également de monter sur
scène pour faire la démonstration de
leur
talentétait
[Musique]
devn pour l'idée pour nous c'était
vraiment destac la lang de faire en
sorte que d'une manière différente que
ce qu'ils ont l'habitude dans des job
dating qu'ils prennent vraiment leur
place et qu'il nous avons besoin de de
les entendre bien sûr nous sommes là
pour les écouter mais ils ont aussi
besoin de s'exprimer et les modes autour
des humoristes graft aujourd'hui qui
sont présents c'est véritablement
décloisonner cette parole au niveau des
jeunes et vraiment faire en sorte que de
manière plus souple moins formelle ils
puissent vraiment bah échanger échanger
avec nous nous dire qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
besoin quelles sont leurs préoccupations
queles sont le leurs attentes et comment
nous demain nous allons les traduire
dans nos plans d'action à venir qui leur
est destiné l'événement révelou talent
s'inscrit dans le plan d'action en
faveur de la réussite de la jeunesse
rignonnaise qui vise à être à l'écoute
des attentes des jeunes afin de
coconstruire avec eux les actions qui
leur seront
dédié moi je crois la jeunesse
reignonaise ma même on était jeune n
tout était un peu hésitant et
aujourd'hui ben président de département
si on m'avait dit ça quand j'étais jeune
j'aurais pas cru et donc je dis à la
jeunesse rayonnaise allez au bout de vos
rêves vous êtes bourré de talent vous
êtes remplis de rêves réaliseer vos
rêves et vous verrez tout est possible
d'anciens bénéficiaires sont également
venus à la rencontre des jeunes pour
partager leur expérience j'ai pu
bénéficier d'aide du département bah du
coup grâce à ma création d'entreprise
donc j'ai bénéficié du fdag le fond
départemental d'aide aux jeunes et le
npjc nouveau pack jeune citoyen qui m'a
permis du coup ben
an
matreise c'est un très très très B
dispositifpart en place et que je
remercie profondément du
coup aussi grâce à en passant par
l'Académie des Dallons j'ai pu avoir mon
permis j'ai pu connaître ma
fibre pour le moment je suis encore
station service mais par la suite je
evenir éducatrice spécialisé la
manifestation s'est terminée par le
concert du groupe saint-louisien
PLL d'autres événements seront organisés
en 2024 dans d'autres micrégions de
lillele